在下方的影片有很多
现在刚才什么的朋友
他们都不小心我吃用的
别人觉得
带你皮膚那么吸引
怎么可能是有动机呢
但其实我真的是
而是我已经有三年没有去做过效果了
我个人的感觉是
我现在带了这个皮膚状态
反而会比吃起来好太多
对有的时候
真的是干净器你的就像
获得可能期待
两期就很大一包红约
应该是我会用一些
家庭办的引起
然后这个是我平时会用的
一个家庭办的光子
它是一颗美他们家的家用眼镇
你这台的不用想的是
非常非常幸运
它让我的膚致
有发生翅膀的肥肤
我自己是感觉
那封吸盟口皮要不复色
办法都应该有控用
它动作到我
而且还可以皮身封汁和皮膚
因为我平时画是真的很忙的办法
那这个用材的话
我的时间成本和金钱成本都很低
就算材的话
一天大概也就被奶茶的起来
但是露起来
就是又快就简单
效果又好
其实这是我第一次给大家分享
我用的美容一起
我又觉得我的这个效果
他任意经验了
我怕是我的个例
所以我又找了十个姐妹
问我一起打卡他
大家帮了一个个时间
大部分的姐妹感受都跟我一样
在用了他几次之后
就觉得皮膚变亮
变通通
也有一些姐妹
坚持用在从一个大流皮的状态
跟的不怎么出有了
而且大家都感觉
在斗斗斗斗动一方面
都有不同程度的感受
然后现在我给大家认试
我是怎么用的
大家在洗完脸
之后呢
一定要把脸上十分擦
大家在练过是干嫂的情况下
直接用它
其实我们在外面用的
可能也是也不要保持干嫂的
这个美容用跟我们说
我们这个不用干心
买回去说
或他会在家里面显示
因为他真的用起来
非常地负面
而是效果就来得很快
对以前我预先没有
你他们会跟我说
你要坚持用
要长时间的用
我们才能看到他的效果
但是这个美容
就是我用以赴
我就能感受到一次的效果
如果我是他说
又一次之后
我要取得一两天
那我妈妈的我每天都用答应
而且他不需要差点
他是这种充电的
所以就在出闻旅行
你也可以带来的
他的原理其实很简单
就是利用六分之一
法司的机关光是我们
接转出闻到我们的皮膚的钱
曾和整体测
短期内可以尽量少皮膚的
出闹和样
华安卓帮助教员盟长
让皮膚变得平台
而且他的效果就来得又快
又不时间
跟我以前买到那种
吃灰的美容一完全不一样
这个就是你又一次
你还会期待第二次的
他这一公分为三个
打温新手从一打开始
就可以了
慢慢的等皮膚势了
之后再分价一下
他就上面有帮我们的脸分成
五个区域
我是一个区域一个区域打的
就跟着他的来就行了
先俄头
然后再到眼尾
练一下还成上下落这样
如果是刚开始用的话
不胆尊有一点刺刺的
但是我个人感觉
这个刺刺的感觉
是在我能够接受的
范围之内的
在下上他这个头
是冰冰两两的
就是编打
编给皮膚降溫震济
最于晚的时候
不用担心会翻手
打的时候
一定要是时候很像
或者是15项屏宁
不要再投一个区域停留太久
我打群人的话
差不多10分钟之内中
打完之后
像一些脚是从宝的地方
可能会有一些溫柚的犯护
不用担心
千里的那种修互不是一样的
我就OK了
甚至可以编分一样
我编用冰水去做一个
降溫震济
浮版里上基本上都会复得七七八八的
透震的呼吸的话
是要用一些修互的产品
这个时候那种
公尚型呼吸品
什么酸、A酸
我们先放一边
我会认识喜欢用这两个
经常跟这个一切来打
这个是传民酸
顿适合练上书色
不均有多多多硬的节的
能央书色
看起来跟家头一
然后都也会带得更快一些
这个是人不是中心话
搭配子水光像我觉得很觉得
我感觉是像同时
企业和光子加神光一样
皮膚的这个光子
在打会变得很好看
很静亮很通透
最后要在企业一个
保持修布的面双
用这个用完之后
我为了成出有会节的上
然后我们要加强保持
用完它的隔天
亲手你们乎乎呢
还是一胸户的为主
如果是成强滴的剪辈的话
就可以用一些低能度的酸了
它来也会放大酸的效果
但是这个就是成强不节的才行
我每次这么做完
隔天那个皮膚状态的好的不行
用心意又通透
而且摸摸起来
它的明显变滑了很多
上装的这个装盖的很好
看我做一碗生的生物生物的
而且我在那里上的都应的时候
只要做这个家里满的光子
我的那个都应不就消失了
费款
所以油皮和油豆皮的姐妹
一定要是使它
它会给你担用护装平效果加倍
然后给它放一个使用屏居图
招就真的来就不会翻车了